على الفريق عبد الفتاح البرهان رئيس مجلس
السياده السودانيين القوات المسلحه ظلت
تتعرضوا لهجوم شديد في الاونه الاخيره
لا يتبع لاي فئه او حذف اضاف البرهان في
كلمه الله امام عدد من ضباط وجنود قاعده
حطاب العسكريه بالخرطوم بحري ان الجيش
السوداني لم ولن يلبي اي نداء سوى نداء
الشعب على حد تعبيره
تتعرض له
هجوم شديد جدا على قيادته عليه ذاته هجومي
[موسيقى]
من هذه القوات المسلحه
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]
الى الحياه السياسيه
السودانيه طالبا منهما الابتعاد عن الجيش
لان الجيش هو الجيش السوداني وليس تابعا
لاي حزب على حد
ناكد للناس اللي بتتهموا الجيش امنه الجيش
موالي لجهه معينه
ولا يوم من الايام
خاص للمؤتمر الوطني المسلحه
[تصفيق]
القوات المسلحه ما هتسمح لاي فئه تعود من
خلاله لا مؤتمر وطني ولا حركه اسلاميه ولا
غيره
ما عندنا نحن نحن جيش جيش السودان